camille et hélène et laura ont attendu
ce moment depuis plusieurs mois alors
qu'elles sont en train de faire leurs
valises elle se remémore le début de
cette belle aventure
les prémices du voyage avaient commencé
un samedi à l'espace rabelais du lit de
la rivière
il ya eu ceux qui s'envolait pour l'inde
de la chine madagascar sur les traces de
leurs ancêtres
les élèves de 4e du collège de la
montagne à les retrouver les racines de
ce premier breton débarqué aux côtés de
malgaches sur cette terre déserte mais
rempli de richesses et les collégiens
iront dans chapet du peuplement
retrouver l'histoire de la réunion
l'histoire des ancêtres également mais
aussi pouvoir inscrire sur le chemin
retour la construction de leur propre
identité
derniers préparatifs donc avant le grand
départ dressé mais en fait je suis trop
ce n'est pas ce à quoi fois que je
voyage donc voilà on va aller à paris
brest lorient et je suis trop content
partir aussi tu prends l'avion
la première fois donc pour camille et
l'aide mais également beaucoup de leurs
camarades de classe que l'on retrouve le
lendemain soir à l'aéroport roland
garros
de voyager
oui aider les enfants à découvrir
d'autres
mieux dans le futur nous passons
ici en même temps il emmène aussi des
choses de montrer qu est-ce que c'est
leur réunion moi c'est ce que du bon
c'est une belle opportunité pour nous de
notre temps n'a pas eu cette chance
l'accord donc on l'apprécié d'autant
plus dans ses initiatives et surtout
donc
la préparation était vraiment très
longue l'attenté est longue mais
maintenant ça lui on est au bout du
tunnel en matière une première
séparation qui inquiète plus les parents
que les enfants
mais le bonheur du voyage prend le
dessus sur le stress du départ et parmi
les familles présentes une grand mère
bretonne jamais t elle va à lorient moi
jamais d
je fais
et tu as hâte de découvrir
après plus de dix heures d'avion nous
retrouvons nos petits réunionnais un peu
fatigué direction la bretagne plus
précisément bresse c'est en autobus que
se fera ce long voyage
il faut tout de même compter plus de six
heures de trajet embarquement donc pour
cette épopée sur les routes du nord de
la france après un arrêt pique nique
c'est de nouveau le paysage qui défile
sous les yeux ébahis de nos collégiens
c'est enfin l'arrivée à brest c'est
notre lieu de destination le collège
diwan ce collège qui a pour
particularité d'enseigner les matières
de l'éducation nationale en langue
bretonne c'est la directrice de
l'établissement qui nous accueille donc
monsieur m'a et les professeurs de
français non sûr il ya une propre
tamouls ce qui va arriver le lendemain
dimanche direction océanopolis ce musée
dédié à l'océan est un endroit
prédestiné pour des jeunes qui vivent
sur une île entourée d'eau océanopolis
sous la visite commence par un atelier
dédié à la formation des coraux
l'occasion pour nos jeunes collégiens
d'être sensibilisés à la sauvegarde des
espèces marines
nous on va parler donc plutôt de coraux
qui se trouve au niveau de porto rico
mieux comprendre l'importance des océans
et surtout de leurs océans qui fourmille
de richesses et donc paradoxalement ils
ont pu percer les secrets à plus de dix
mille kilomètres de chez eux générant
aucun combat ces verrines elles sont là
elles sont la tension le côté comme ça
l'extrémité y en a deux promis après le
requin il a fait un très très bon odorat
il peut sentir une proie à plusieurs
kilomètres de 10
et il peut la sentir encore plus
facilement 6 à 600 jours de la visite
ben que les gens aiment la chaleur et
c'est pour ça qu'il vient d'un désir le
docteur le mode de vie des animaux
la reproduction ben
que c'est aux animaux sont pas dangereux
nous sommes lundi 13 octobre et cette
journée de lundi va être très
enrichissante pour nos petits
réunionnais mais également pour nos
petits bretons qui vont faire de très
belles découvertes
les journées des changes qui débute par
une présentation de la région bretonne
et du collège du monde suit les mêmes
programmes que partout ailleurs dans
toutes les classes simplement la
spécificité c'est que la majeure partie
de l'enseignement se fait en breton que
la langue de vie de l'établissement est
le breton ce sont ensuite les élèves qui
se succèdent pour mettre en avant la
culture particulière de la région crêpes
en bretagne c'est vraiment un seul plus
important ah bon il ya deux types de le
crack une qui mangent elles donc en
entrée ou alors on peut leur histoire
donc c'est la farine de blé noir du
sarrasin auxerre nous voit la compagnie
de jambon de rue hier voilà et donc et
en dessert ils écrivent donc froment
l'ajout du beurre du sucre voilà donc
c'est bon là ça ça cale un peu france a
à présent la plus facile
c'est ensuite au tour des réunionnais de
faire découvrir notre île et le collège
de la montagne où se trouve l'île de la
réunion déjà bien entendu parler oui ça
trouve dans l'océan indien alors là mons
moi je voudrais pas l'afrique non mais
bon afrique ici madagascar
nous non de la réunion c'est à travers
un abécédaire que chaque élève fait la
présentation de l'île de la réunion
t comme dauphin parce que la réunion est
une île et au sein d'une aide d'état de
nous
c'est un animal qui n'ont une journée de
découvertes et de rencontres qui s'est
poursuivie avec différents ateliers
d'un côté les bretons et de l'autre la
réunion de région qui se retrouvent
autour de leur culture leurs traditions
et une envie de partage en fait le but
est violente et ici avec avec des
pierres ifs et sugar initiés ben tu
gagnes beaucoup de points avec les
bénévoles n'est pas les nombreux tombe
un peu plus loin on danse au rythme de
la musique bretonne des cours de danse
qui ont donné lieu à une belle farandole
dans la cour du collège
une journée qui a connu un vrai moment
d'émotion avec cette fois ci la
découverte de musique de chaque région
la réunion qui a conquis le public
breton avec son maloya des émotions
fortes et des embrassades à la hauteur
de ses amitiés naissantes entre des
adolescents heureux d'avoir découvert
l'autre
cette journée a permis de rapprocher
deux régions du bout du monde et
quelques heures plus tard c'est
l'arrivée à ploemeur au centre régional
de culture bretonne et celtique
au programme un concert d'une formation
musicale bretonne
des musiciens qui ont souhaité entendre
la musique réunionnaise et ses basses
terres qui est de nouveau à l'honneur
pour illustrer notre culture musicale
autre moment fort du séjour la traversée
jusqu'à la citadelle pour la visite du
musée de la compagnie des indes
c'est en effet ici que tout a commencé
et c'est d'ici que sont partis les
bretons qui ont débarqué un jour sur
l'île de la réunion encore totalement
déserte un lieu important donc dans la
genèse de ce projet de voyage initié par
le département
c'est une guide qui nous renvoie au
xviiie siècle lorsque jean baptiste
colbert initie la compagnie des cintres
pente colbert et louis xiv décident de
fonder la compagnie des indes
ils vont chercher un lieu pour la
construction de leurs bateaux et la
construction de leur bateau ils vont
choisir la rade
cette entreprise gigantesque qui a
permis l'échangé de marchandises nous
renvoie l'océan indien et à l'île de la
réunion après avoir expliqué
l'organisation des échanges et les
conditions de la traversée des océans
les collégiens des couples à celles qui
traitent des mascareignes
on s'installe donc sur ces îles au début
du xviiie siècle pour y faire escale
qu'est ce qu'une escale pourquoi est-ce
qu'on s'y arrête opposé pour se reposer
ça c'est une raison pour en baver le
bain de la réunion terre d'escale l'île
maurice et son hôpital une visite
enrichissante pour le collège de la
montagne faisait d'étrangers pour vendre
des produits des objets et quelques
esclaves
qu'on peut aussi coquelles rire quelques
pays
est-ce que tu as trouvé ça intéressant
c'était fascinant
les apports des objets de loin et des
esclaves
ici il y avait un breton et 10,9
malgache lâché à la fin mai à la réunion
un séjour en bretagne qui s'achève et
prochaine destination et pas des
moindres paris et découvrir paris c'est
avant tout découvrir le métro et pour la
majorité des enfants
c'est une première
et la visite du jour n'est pas n'importe
quelle visite un lieu dédié à l'opéra
bienvenue au palais garnier
notre guide ce matin pour vous faire
découvrir à l'histoire de ce bâtiment
vous savez votre monument incontournable
de la capitale la tour eiffel c'est du
trocadéro sous un temps gris et pluvieux
que nos jeunes collégiens découvrent la
vieille dame de fer après la tour eiffel
c'est la plus belle avenue du monde et
l'arc de triomphe qui attendent nos
jeunes réunionnais qui ont tout de même
un peu froid et c'est pratiquement la
fin du séjour avec les souvenirs qui
s'inscrivent dans les têtes mais aussi
dans les carnets de voyage dans la
chambre l'heure est au bouclage de la
valise à castellane et les autres
feuillette leurs carnets et se
souviennent
on est parce que j voi on a rencontré
des collégiens
il étudie le breton n'a découvert leur
culture le golan le sport un sport de
combat culturel
ben on a fait football gaélique les
palettes la danse automne le creps était
bien s'est bien amusé avec les musées et
où on a appris plein de choses on est
allé voir des musées pour dire qui est
arrivé le premier à la réunion
la danse bretonne la bretagne terre de
peuplement de la réunion et des petits
réunionnais sur les traces de leurs
ancêtres la boucle est bouclée
retrouvailles avec la terre à une nes
mais des tête remplie de souvenirs des
connexions établies à jamais avec nos
ancêtres ceux qui sont à l'origine du
peuplement de la haine
des mains